[Musique]
mais bonsoir à tous mardi 11 juin
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale sur tv 60,18 voici
les titres de ce journal mauvais
résultat aux européennes d'émission de
laurent wauquiez départ de valérie
pécresse le parti des républicains à
traverse une crise sans précédent quel
avenir pour la formation alors que
certains élus appellent ou soutient
emmanuel macron nous en parlons avec
othman nasri président du groupe plr au
conseil régional d'île de france le
cyclisme célébré dans les yvelines le
week-end dernier le département
accueillait deux événements coupe du
monde de bmx au vélodrome nationale et
fait du vélo à rambouillet lieu de
départ de la dernière étape du tour de
france 2010 9
et puis le rendez-vous revient à saint
quentin en yvelines le deuxième trophée
des entreprises se déroule jeudi saint
ladre multisports entièrement dédié aux
sociétés du territoire présentation avec
bernard des bancs vice président de
l'agglomération en charge des sports
mais d'abord ils sont trois maires de
droite de commune yvelinoise a appelé au
soutien à emmanuel macron le maire ait
l'air de poissy karl olive et les et il
est divers droite de saint germain en
laye et conflans sainte honorine
arnaud péricard et laurent bros ils font
partie des 72 élus locaux a signé cette
tribune parue dans le jdd pour
officialiser leur soutien au
gouvernement sans pour autant se rallier
à la république en marche
nous refusons de nous réduire à une
étiquette à une consigne de vote
justifie les signataires est démarche
avant tout ils le disent pour la
réussite impératifs de la france qui
implique la réussite du président de la
république et de son gouvernement
bonsoir othman natrue pense à vous êtes
le président a du groupe l'est
républicain au conseil régional
d'ile-de-france candidat également aux
élections municipales à trappes on va en
parler dans un instant d'abord c'est 72
élus de droite et du centre qui appelle
à soutenir emmanuel macron et le
gouvernement parmi eux je le disais le
maire les républicains de poissy karl
olive a après le départ de valérie
pécresse est ce que c'est un nouveau
coup dur pour la droite pour les
républicains le coup dur pour la droite
pour les républicains plus précisément
c'est évidemment le score aux
européennes
et quand on a un score comme celui qu'on
a eues il y à peine deux semaines
aujourd'hui il faut savoir se remettre
en cause le pire ce serait d'expliquer
que rien n'a changé qu'il faut juste
continuer comme avant
moi je fais partie de ceux qui depuis
deux ans a alerté sur un certain nombre
de difficultés sur la ligne
sur la stratégie sur la présidence de
laurent wauquiez moi j'ai critiqué à
certains égards donc faut savoir se
remettre en cause on peut pas continuer
à faire de la politique comme avant et
c'est vrai que à droite on s'est
beaucoup reposé sur nos lauriers qu'il
faut savoir réinventer quelque chose de
complètement nouveau
pendant deux ans on n'a pas eu de
discours par exemple sur la question
environnementale qui est un vrai sujet
que pourtant on met en oeuvre pour un
certain nombre d'élus on a dans cette
agglomération même des maires de droite
du centre qui font un travail
remarquable sur cette question et
pourtant au national on ne savait pas
l'incarner donc c'est normal qu'il y ait
une remise en cause profonde chacun
prend sa part et chacun dans ce cadre-là
dit ce qu'il a à dire est ce que disait
arnaud péricard le maire de saint
germain en laye sur les ondes de rtl
c'est que la droite aujourd'hui
finalement pour lui elle est incarnée
notamment par le premier ministre
edouard philippe par le ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire est est ce que
c'est bien ça la situation où vous vous
croyez vous à une troisième voie celle
dont parle et valérie pécresse une
troisième voie entre la république en
marge d'un côté le front national de
l'autre le rassemblement national
si on laisse le face à face entre la
république en marche et le front
national s'installer dans notre pays
c'est que c'est forcément quelque chose
de très dangereux parce que ça voudrait
dire que la seule alternative
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron ce serait
front national moi je souhaite la
réussite des manuels vaincrons bien sûr
tout le monde le souhaite
la question c'est comment on fait et à
chaque fois qu'il ya une réforme qui va
dans le bon sens il faut le dire il faut
la soutenir
et puis s'il y a des choses des impasses
des angles morts des choses sur
lesquelles ce gouvernement est encore
attendue et bien faut aussi avoir la
liberté de pouvoir le dire en étant
cohérent avec soi même
moi c'est ce que je fais depuis deux ans
mais un certain nombre à y prendre notre
part valérie pécresse aussi là dit elle
compte le faire aujourd'hui
en dehors de l'appareil des républicains
qui effectivement levée des appareils
sont mortels ce n'est pas ce qui compte
ce qui compte ce sont les idées des
valeurs derrière et donc je vais pas
venir de la droite il passe par par
cette troisième voie dont on parle
valérie pécresse il peut se faire au
sein des républicains ou à votre avis
les noms 7 membres sentiment c'est qu'il
faut aussi savoir inventer des choses
nouvelles et qu'on ne peut pas
simplement continuer comme si rien
n'avait changé la réalité c'est qu'il
faut qu'on se remette profondément en
cause et pour sa construire des choses
nouvelles et forcément utile mais pardon
on le faisait déjà dans nos territoires
pour un certain nombre dans un certain
nombre de villes avec des constructions
politiques adaptées aux réalités locales
et qui ne sont pas dans les clivages
partisans qui sont parfois un petit peu
stérile qu'on connaît au national
avant de passer à la trappe on vous sait
proche de valérie pécresse est ce que
vous allez participer à peut-être à son
initiative de créer cette troisième voie
celle de don elle appelle quitter les
républicains pour participer à cette
initiative comme l'a fait alexandra du
blanchet qui vous former un binôme lors
des élections à la fédération des
yvelines des républicains puisque est ce
que vous allez quitter le parti
moi je réunis mais élu parce que vous
l'avez rappelé je préside un groupe qui
composait de 80 élus au conseil régional
d'île de france ils sont pas tous les
républicains ont aussi un certain nombre
qui depuis longtemps des gens ont rendu
leur carte n'ont jamais at elle adhérant
aux républicains qui sont des
indépendants et c'est important que vous
voyez que les choses ne soient pas aussi
clivé qu'on peut en avoir l'impression
quand on suit uniquement aujourd'hui les
chaînes d'information donc je vais
d'abord avoir cette discussion avec eux
puis vous l'avez rappelé j'ai un combat
local lequel je compte me consacrer donc
je vous dirai à ce moment là aussi ce
que je fais à titre personnel mais je
contribue effectivement et je soutiens
la démarche de valérie pécresse qui est
de construire un espace politique
différents équilibres et intelligent
moderne et qu'ils puissent tenir compte
à la fois des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres mais aussi de la réalité du monde
d'aujourd'hui nos plates décision prise
encore sur ce point là on l'a compris
rassembler au delà des étiquettes c'est
l'ambition que vous affichez aux
élections municipales 2020 vous êtes
déclaré vous êtes déclaré candidat
officiellement donc à trappes jeudi
dernier cette ville où vous êtes
conseiller municipal d'opposition c'est
votre deuxième candidature après 2014 où
vous étiez arrivé second avec plus de 30
% des voix vous allez vous présenter
face aux électeurs sans étiquette mais
moi je vais faire exactement ce que j'ai
fait la dernière fois puisque je vous
l'avais rappelé les trappistes m'en
accorder la seconde place lors des
dernières élections municipales avec un
score de plus de 30% et je m'étais
engagé à l'époque à être présent au
lendemain de cette élection quoi qu'il
arrive et ça fait donc cinq ans que je
dirige l'opposition municipale avec
d'autres élus qui sont de toutes
sensibilités avec un groupe qui a
grandit d'ailleurs puisque nous avons
des élus de la majorité municipale aussi
qui sont venus vers nous parce que ça
fait cinq ans qu'on défend avec
constance les idées les mêmes valeurs
via notamment le général de moniot salué
la bo qui sont deux anciens conseillers
de la majorité est également ancien
maire adjoint de la commune qui était à
gauche en rappel le maire divers gauche
de trappes c'est guy malandain
ça veut dire quoi c'est le projet qui
compte davantage que les étiquettes
aujourd'hui oui et c'est pour ça que la
dernière fois nous avions déjà
construits un rassemblement qui
s'appelait trappe citoyens
qui existe encore aujourd'hui et qui
encore une fois la maison commune de
tous ceux qui pensent qu'il faut donner
un nouveau souffle à trappes
on l'avait c'était déjà notre diagnostic
en 2014 je le pense d'autant plus
aujourd'hui et le fait qu'il y ait
effectivement des élus qui nous
rejoignent prouve que notre diagnostic
était le bon et qu'aujourd'hui le
clivage attrape il n'est pas entre à
droite et la gauche
moi je ne sais pas ce que c'est qu'un
projet l air pur trappe
je sais par contre qu'il ya un vrai
sujet sur les questions de mixité
sociale que sur la réussite scolaire le
maximum n'est pas fait je sais que c'est
la priorité peut-être rattrape c'est la
réussite scolaire aujourd'hui avait
incontestablement le prochain mandat
doit être axée sur cette question de
l'éducation de la réussite scolaire du
niveau dans nos écoles à trappes qu'il
faut qu'on puisse améliorer sensiblement
et compris parce que derrière il ya un
sujet de mixité sociale mais on le doit
vraiment à tous à tous les trappistes et
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai été chercher
des responsabilités politiques à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines dont je suis aujourd'hui de
vice président en charge du
développement économique à la région ile
de france également
c'est à dire qu aujourd hui vous avez
cette expérience qui peut vous servir
pour trappe
eh bien écoutez je me sens aujourd'hui
une responsabilité par rapport à trappes
qui encore une fois m'a fait confiance
et j'ai choisi de rester fidèle à
trappes et c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
je pense que je peux y être utile en
tout cas à construire un projet une
majorité municipale qui soit équilibrée
qui soit très loin des clivages
nationaux qui n'ont pas de sens à
trappes mais qu'il soit par contre sur
un projet qui soit crédible sans
concession sur les valeurs et sur les
idées qu'ils soient avec l'appui des
partenaires agglomération département
région et l'état que je sais vigilant
aussi sur la situation de trappe
et puis surtout un projet qui puisse
tirer les gens vers le haut et vous
l'avez dit la question de l'école est
évidemment la question clé aujourd'hui à
trappes là en face à vous il ya bien sûr
le maire sortant didier malandain qui
est en lice pour un quatrième mandat qui
a annoncé officiellement sa candidature
quel regard vous portez sur sur son
action à la tête de la ville moi je n'ai
jamais été dans l'opposition caricatural
ce qui va dans le bon sens la même
manière prénationale je le fais aussi au
conseil municipal et je vote les
délibérations qui me semble aller dans
le bon sens donc je reconnais à guy
malandain d'avoir oeuvré notamment sur
ses deux premiers mandats notamment sur
le plan urbain c'est une réalité et tant
mieux ça s'est fait avec d'ailleurs
l'argent qui viennent de l'état par des
gouvernements d'ailleurs de droite en
tout cas c'était jean louis borloo qui
avait porté cette rénovation urbaine
probablement qu'elle était nécessaire
mais une fois qu'on a fait les façades
une fois qu'on a fait l'esthétique la
réalité c'est qu'on ne sait pas assez
occupé des gens et c'est pour ça que
cette question de l'école dont on
pourrait aussi parler de la question de
l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle sont aujourd'hui les
questions
fondamentale et guy malandain est un
urbaniste de formation moi j'ai plutôt
la fibre économique et c'est pour ça que
naturellement je vais aller plutôt sur
ces sujets là mais je crois que ce
dernier mandat était vraiment le mandat
du temps perdu je crois que encore une
fois en 2014 déjà il y avait un
essoufflement une usure et
qu'aujourd'hui di malanda ne peut rien
apporter de nouveau pour l'avenir de la
ville il faut donc qu'on écrive une
nouvelle histoire la suite de l'avenir
de trappes d'une manière que je viens de
vous décrire avec une majorité large qui
soit fidèle représentative à lettres de
la ville avec une équipe de compétences
et un projet qui soit encore une fois
crédible et financé c'est ce que je vais
m'atteler à démontrer aidé durant les
prochains mois une dernière question sur
une autre candidature celle de mustapha
larbaoui qui est l'ex président de
l'étoile sportive de trappes il a
confirmé qu'il prendrait part à ces
élections reste à déterminer s'il sera
tête de liste ou policier est ce qu'une
candidature commune des discussions
peuvent avoir lieu avec eux avec
mustapha larbaoui vous ce n'est pas à
l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et de respect
pour mustapha larbaoui qui est un acteur
de terrain important sur traque qui a
beaucoup fait pour trappe personne ne
lui conteste cela notamment par la vie
associative qui l'a mené je chante
chacun reconnaît toutes ses qualités
mais notre dos des démarches aujourd'hui
ne sont pas tout à fait similaire en ce
qui me concerne je suis dans une
démarche de construction politique
effectivement avec ma casquette d'élu je
crois que mustapha la ba oui aujourd'hui
vont à la rencontre des trappistes sur
quelque chose qui n'est pas d'ordre
politique mais qui et qui vient d'abord
de l'associatif donc naturellement je
souhaite qu'on puisse discuter complice
qu'on puisse naturellement se voir ça
vaut pour lui comme pour tous ceux qui
veulent continuer à faire avancer trappe
et c'est pour ça que j'ai fait cet appel
en novembre dernier certains y ont déjà
répondu naturellement on continuera à
discuter derrière encore une fois un
seul intérêt qui est celui des
trappistes et de l'avenir de la ville et
vous savez qu'on l'a parfois reproché
moi je dis les choses à ma manière c'est
aussi ça le respect de dire les choses
même quand elles ne sont pas agréables à
entendre mais encore une fois qu'on
puisse préparer l'avenir de la ville de
manière intelligente de manière sereine
et de manière crédible
merci othman municipal d'opposition
attrapé vous êtes candidat pour ce
scrutin des élections municipales en
2020 sous la liste trappe citoyens dans
l'actualité également ces chiffres
inquiétants publiés par santé publique
france l'été dernier entre juin et fin
septembre 58 noyades accidentelles ont
fait 18 morts en ile-de-france est
l'équivalent d'un incident tous les deux
jours un bilan en grande augmentation
depuis la dernière étude qui date de
2015 co
principal de ces drames qui touchent
elles davantage les enfants de moins de
6 ans dans des piscines familiales le
manque de surveillance des parents et
aussi la mauvaise pratique de la nage le
sport le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillait ce
week-end deux manches de coupe du monde
de bmx 260 concurrents issus de 25
nationalités se sont affrontés
l'événement affiché complet mélanie
poquet et au rayon des tribunes pleines
à craquer près de 12000 personnes sont
venues encourager les meilleurs pilotes
de bmx au stade vélodrome de 50 ans
c'est assez agréable mais en tant que
tout s'est tu
cette effervescence c'est très bon ce
qui plaît c'est de voir tous ces pilotes
qui sont vraiment très fort et qui roule
vraiment in mboa très supérieur près de
deux cent soixante concurrents dont 100
français se sont affrontés pour les
cinquième et sixième manche de la coupe
du monde de la discipline
c'est chez nous c'est là puisqu'on
connaît le mieux donc toute la saison se
prépare dessus et c'est vraiment
l'événement le plus important pour nous
de cette saison
de plus en plus de pratiquants de bmx
ans dans notre pays et puis ensuite sous
l'angle de l'accompagnement vers le haut
niveau
le pôle olympique ici à saint quentin il
contribue beaucoup mais on a cette
capacité à s'installer de manière assez
permanente sur les podiums au niveau
international
pari réussi pour les français manon
valentino a terminé dimanche sur la plus
haute marche du podium
les petits français était là à crier
encore et encore et je me suis dit il
faut que j'aille faut que j'essaie j'ai
poussé dans les bosses s'est passé c'est
incroyable d'avoir gagné ici
chez les hommes le français joris daudet
termine 3e samedi-- deuxième dimanche
les prochaines manches de la coupe du
monde se dérouleront les 14 et 15
septembre aux états unis et à l'occasion
de ses manches de coupe du monde de bmx
la fédération française de cyclisme a
récompensé l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et le département
est les deux collectivités ont reçu le
label terre d'excellence cycliste
valorisant les territoires pourvu d'une
offre locale et d'équipements tourner
vers le cyclisme et qui accueille aussi
régulièrement des compétitions
d'importance est le label a pour
objectif notamment de valoriser
l'attractivité la visibilité de ces
territoires et les yvelines possède
environ 850 km de voies pour la pratique
du vélo écouter cette réaction au micro
de mélanie poker c'est effectivement une
belle reconnaissance de notre de notre
appui sur auprès de la fédération
française de cyclisme
pour développer ce sport et nous le
développons au niveau du sport alors
pour des professionnels et des amateurs
mais aussi en termes de mobilité
puisqu'il ya un gros effort de fait sur
le développement en
en faveur de la création de pistes
cyclables pour permettre à tous les
yvelines moi de pouvoir utiliser
facilement ses pistes cyclables ou pour
aller travailler ou pour le week end ou
faire du sport une réaction côté
département et pour réagir côté
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines bernard débord bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le neuvième vice-président
pardon de saint quentin en yvelines en
charge des sports
recevant un tel label de la fédération
française de cyclisme qu'est ce que ça
représente pour l'agglomération déjà
pour le président de saint quentin en
yvelines et l'ensemble des élus c'est un
honneur de recevoir ce label
ça prouve le travail qui est fait au
quotidien depuis déjà de nombreuses
années notamment à travers nombreuses
pistes cyclables qui ont été élaborés
historiquement sur les sept premières
communes et puis aujourd'hui on essaye
d'avoir le même niveau de performances
en piste cyclable à l'échelle des douze
communes s'est dit innocent km
aujourd'hui deux voies dédiées aux vélos
sur saint-quentin chute a fait alors il
est vrai qu'aujourd'hui encore des
ruptures entre les différentes voies et
qu'on va petit à petit comblé mais c'est
aussi la volonté avec la fédération
française de cyclisme et le département
d'aller bien au delà on travaille sur un
plan vélo que j'espère avoir le plaisir
de vous présenter un jour sur cette
antenne avec le but de faire du vélo un
acteur essentiel des yvelines en
commençant par les tout-petits avec le
savoir rouler et en mettant un certain
nombre de dispositifs qui vont jusqu'au
sport loisir et au sport de compétition
vous avez tout à l'heure à montrer
effectivement la compétition qu'on avait
ce week-end on a fait comble au niveau 2
des spectateurs c'est un spectacle
merveilleux
yazdi a lui aussi qualifié au qui arrive
avec bien évidemment le vélodrome lille
de loisirs et la colline d'elancourt qui
auront donc le plaisir d'accueillir des
épreuves des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
alors il y aura du vélo mais pas qu'eux
au programme du douzième trophée des
entreprises c'est ce jeudi avec un
départ et une arrivée au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
220 équipes vont y participer soit 600
participants pourquoi il est important
pour l'agglomération de leur proposer
chaque année ce trophée d entre eux
place
servir qu'on a souhaité entre le sport
et les entreprises n'oublions pas que au
niveau des entreprises saint quentin en
yvelines et le deuxième est pôle
économique de l'ouest parisien qu on a
tout un axe de développement notamment
avec le paris saclay ce qui cube et au
delà en fait de l'attractivité au niveau
des entreprises
on a un deuxième pilier d'attractivité
qui est le sport avec un grand nombre
d'acteurs à commencer par le monde
associatif mais aussi un grand nombre de
manifestations régionales nationales
internationales que nous avons pu le
pouvoir que nous accueillons et donc
c'est un territoire économique un
territoire sportif qui a des passerelles
aussi par israël et que le sport et
l'entreprise permettent aussi de pouvoir
créer des liens au niveau d'une
entreprise
on le voit pour tous ceux qui ont
participé notamment pour ceux qui
veulent y participer cette année il ya
la volonté de faire du team building de
se retrouver ensemble de partager des
émotions de partager le savoir d'aller
plus loin au delà de ses limites
malgré obligatoirement des collisions et
de gagner ensemble et gagner ensemble
c'est aussi bien valable pour le sport
que l'entreprise vous avez tout de suite
vu le lien qui peut avoir permis de
rencontrer aussi des entreprises dans un
autre cadre que celui du bureau
exactement et on a la chance de le faire
dans un cadre qui est magnifique
déjà avec le vélodrome d'où partira en
fête donc cette épreuve et surtout lille
de loisirs qui est dans un cadre
environnemental d'excellence et ça c'est
une chance au milieu des entreprises
d'avoir des cadres comme ça il ya
beaucoup de gens d'ailleurs qui
participent
d'autres découvrent le cadre et sont
invités comme ça elle participer
autrement avec it ont pris leurs enfants
et donc c'est quelque chose de
formidable
vous disiez donc six ans en fait c'est
666 en 68 jeux ça se remplit vite on est
un taux de croissance de 10% par an ce
qui prouve que les gens en parlent et
j'ai encore eu d'ailleurs des petites
entreprises qui m'ont dit on s'y est
pris un petit peu tard
on aurait souhaité participer à cette
année mais on est certain de dédit
revenir l'année prochaine donc oui
ça prend de l'ampleur et on est ravi il
ya de plus en plus aussi de bénévoles il
faut compter aussi sur les bénévoles qui
nous aident pour le réaliser mais aussi
des entreprises qui sont des entreprises
partenaires
sur le plan financier et sur le plan
qu'a vraiment avec un côté
environnemental cette année qui est
beaucoup plus mis en avant notamment
avec la céleste qui nous a rejoint donc
de ce côté là et on a fait signer une
charte à l'ensemble des entreprises et
des participants de façon à respecter
donc le cadre à faire des efforts
notamment du covoiturage nous avons mis
à disposition avec la savak donc des bus
électriques vous râlez du vélodrome
jusque donc à lille de loisirs pour tous
les spectateurs pour ceux qui ne
participent pas les autres ça va plutôt
faire l'entraînement en y allant mais
vous voyez qu'il ya tout un aspect aussi
environnemental qui est mis en avant et
c'est important parce que sur saint
quentin en yvelines
n'oublions pas qu'on a la chance d'avoir
un territoire très vert avec beaucoup de
10 pas se protéger et il faut absolument
que quand on fait du sport de ce type là
on puisse avoir le côté environnemental
et respect de la nature en 10 secondes
on arrive à la fin de son côté ben
qu'est-ce qui est au programme
cette épreuve donc qu'on va commencer
par une course à pied de 4,6 km derrière
donc une course d'orientation de 2 km 5
avec dix balises donc qui seront à
pointer avec bien évidemment des aspects
différents pour chaque épreuve
une épreuve de golf donc pour le
meilleur des droits puisque chaque
équipe compte trois concurrents relais
vtt de 2 5 km par équipes du bike and
run donc et puis donc pour terminer une
épreuve de radeaux et une course de 1.5
km donc cette épreuve avec trop cheap de
participants des équipes hommes des
équipes femmes et des équipes mixtes et
je peux vous dire aussi que nous aurons
la chance d'avoir un
à sur un concours aussi faute au delà
des 3 premiers donc par chaque épreuve
des animations des animations et chacun
des participants est qui qui aura en
fait des des admirateurs qui prennent
les photos bas plus les photos seront
belles plus elles seront un petit pic et
auquel seront prises en compte et entre
toutes les informations sur le site du
trophée des entreprises qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran merci bernard et sans
oublier un drone qui va survoler
l'épreuve avec des photos à couper le
souffle qui donneront envie pour la
prochaine épreuve dont de 2020 et je
l'espère encore 10% plus on l'espère de
rêver je rappelle vous êtes le
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge des
sports et on vous fera vivre ce trophée
des entreprises sur notre antenne
le départ de la dernière étape du tour
de france est dans un peu plus d'un mois
le 28 le 28 juillet le peloton
s'élancera du parc du château de
rambouillet pour rallier les
champs-elysées à paris pour célébrer
l'événement le département des yvelines
organisée ce week-end la fête du vélo
c'était à rambouillet
le reportage de mélanie poker la course
est lancée les concurrents partent à la
chasse au maillot jaune imposera bicloo
était l'une des animations de la fête du
biou rambouillet faut les former des
plus jeune âge on pourra voir des futurs
champions mais aussi
bah voila je pense que le vélo à une
belle perspective d'admis d'avenir on
n'est ni juste par hasard faire un petit
tour dans le château on s'est retrouvé à
voir toutes ces animations cas on a
passé un petit peu de temps avec nos
enfants
j'ai encore les animations et tout c'est
sympa si on a un petit loulou lac est en
train de s'amuser sur le manège
activités virtuelles draisienne pour les
plus petits démonstrations de vtt trial
le public a aussi pu tester une
quinzaine de vélos particulier certains
sortis tout droit de l'imagination de
passionner les vélos rigolos ce sont des
vélos qui sont modifiés
techniquement c'est à dire qu'on modifie
les caractéristiques on joue au niveau
des roues des directions des chaînes et
tout ça de manière à proposer des vélos
différent de ce qu'on a l'habitude de
rencontrer et sous une approche ludique
et amusante
un week-end à deux roues organisée par
le département département est une terre
de vélo et se veut est une terre de vélo
l'idée c'est de
c'est d'avoir une culture vélo sur le
département et les yvelinois m
ce cette mobilité ce mode de déplacement
doux
c'est aussi c'est aussi ça le vélo c'est
à la fois du sport un loisir mais aussi
un mode de déplacement
rambouillet les yvelines multiplie les
animations autour du vélo depuis le mois
d'avril prochain grand rendez vous avec
les professionnels le peloton s'élancera
du château le 28 juillet prochain
cet événement est également porté par le
département des yvelines la finale du
concours robotique se tenait à mantes la
jolie en fin de semaine dernière et 10
collèges du territoire se sont affrontés
pour la quatrième édition retour avec
patrick jacques de dixmude et aureilhan
ce depuis plusieurs mois 300 collégiens
yvelinois travail en vue de la finale de
ce concours de robotique
ils ont dû apprendre et réaliser un
robot bateliers le thème retenu pour
cette quatrième édition
on a travaillé d'abord sur un plan mais
plan papier donc le robot il avance à
une certaine vitesse sur le plateau qui
est un peu plus granulés il est il
avance une autre vitesse
voilà donc il a fallu
en fer sera justement là avant d'avoir
la finalité de le programme les élèves
ont dû créer un robot capable de
récupérer des conteneurs pour les
emmener dans une zone de déchargement
porté par le département des yvelines ce
projet est un fil rouge tout au long de
l'année scolaire et à plusieurs visée
pédagogique
l'objectif de ce concours est de ce
projet c'est travailler à une manière
différente des compétences du programme
scolaire
donc ils vont travailler l'expression
orale la programmation les mathématiques
les langues étrangères éventuellement
les arts plastiques tout ça de manière
transverse en travaillons pour certains
pour la plupart pour la première fois en
mode projet durant toute la journée le
jury composé de sept personnes à évaluer
les compétences et les réalisations des
dix collèges en lice on a une gueule
davies il nous permet d'analyser d'une
part la présentation qui est faite au
départ et après deux circuits que
réalise le robot il ya une note un peu
général à la fin et puis aussi cooper du
jury l'effort il ya quelque chose passe
à ne plus que l'heureuse cette année
c'est le collège montaigne de conflans
sainte honorine qui a remporté le grand
prix une cinquième édition est d'ores et
déjà programmée pour l'année prochaine
avec comme thème le robot écolo
[Musique]
du jazz toujours plus de jazz le style a
la cote dans le département à notre
festival lui est dédié pour en parler
mélanie poquet bonsoir ça pour votre
chronique coup de coeur culture où nous
emmener vous ce soir on part à
maisons-laffitte du 14 au 23 juin c'est
le 14e festival dédié à ce style
cette année onze concerts sont
programmés avec en ouverture un concert
événement au château de la ville vont se
produire pour l'occasion trois artistes
reconnus sur la scène internationale
le guitariste sylvain luc le batteur
nicolas viccaro et le bassiste richard
bona
écoutons un extrait d'un live de ce
dernier
[Musique]
baby même un film en vo
et c'est un festival mais là nous tirons
aussi chaque année des hommages didier
lockwood l'an passé cette année le
public pourra redécouvrir les notes de
michel petrucciani
le pianiste et compositeur français
décédé il ya tout juste vingt ans un
musicien à part dans l'histoire du jazz
et des précoces prolifique et à
l'hommage sera rendu le jeudi 20 juin à
la salle malesherbes au piano laurent
coulondre très marquée par le jazzman
alors la 14e édition du maisons laffitte
jazz festival débute le 14 juin prochain
d'autres artistes vont bien su rythmer
les différentes dates de concert et pour
les écouter et les découvrir direction
le site du festival
merci mélanie d'autres actualités
culturelles dans votre émission c'est
après le journal le 7-8 culture la fin
de cette édition belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]